all right i have a problem here jacob
and emily ride a ferris wheel at a
carnival in billings montana the wheel
has a 16 meter diameter so let me draw
the wheel there's a 16 meter diameter
let's say let me draw it big so we have
a lot of space
so it has a 16 meter diameter so what's
its radius going to be is radius is
going to be half of that right
so if i were to draw
its radius
it's radius
i'll just draw it like that
it's radius it's a 16 meter diameter so
its radius is going to be eight meters
with its lowest point above the ground
oh this lowest point one meter above the
ground so it's the lowest point is right
here
this is its lowest point
and that is one meter above the ground
so this distance right here is one
meter fair enough
assume that jacob and emily's height h
above the ground is a sinusoidal
function of time where
where t equals zero represents the
lowest point on the wheel so this is at
point t equals zero
right here t equals zero lowest point of
the wheel right equation for h oh i
think i forgot so let me re-read it
jacob and emily ride a ferris wheel at a
carnival in buildings montana the wheel
has a 16 meter diameter we did that
and turns at three revolutions per
minute so it turns at three revolutions
per minute
three revolutions per minute with its
lowest point one meter above the ground
assume that jacob and emily's height h
above the ground is a sinusoidal
function of time where t equals zero so
we need to write a function of h their
distance above the ground as a function
of time
and they're saying that time is given in
seconds so first of all they're telling
us three revolutions every minute right
so that's three revolutions
three revolutions per
60 seconds
and that's the same thing as one
revolution
per
20 seconds right i just divide kind of
both sides of the per by by three
for 20 seconds and one revolution is how
many degrees one revolution is 360
degrees so it's 360
360 degrees
per
20 seconds
and if you're going 360 degrees for 20
seconds let's divide you know the per
you can just kind of use this as an
equal sign or an equation
what's 360 degrees per 20 seconds that
means you're going to go what 18 degrees
just divide both sides by 20. 18 degrees
per
second
18 degrees per second i mean we could
have done this with a numerator and
denominator three revs per you know you
could have said
three revs
over 60 seconds
that's actually how i should have done
it three revs over 60 seconds is equal
to one rev
over 20 seconds which is equal to 360
degrees
over 20 seconds which is equal to 18
degrees that's degrees per second
right so we're going to travel 18
degrees per second so the total number
of degrees we've traveled in t if t t
seconds is going to be so see
if we say the angle
that's
the angle from our starting point so
let's say we're
let's say we've traveled t seconds and
we're right there
what is
let's drop a little
altitude right here
what is this angle going to be or this
angle is right here what is this angle
going to be how many how many degrees
have we traveled
well we say we travel 18 degrees per
second so if we travel t seconds this is
going to be 18
18 t
degrees right
all right so let's see if we can figure
out how their height as a function of of
this uh well as a function of t or as a
function of this angle right here
so
at what is this height right here
up here it's one meter plus the radius
because this distance right here is
eight so we could say that this is
this point right here is h is equal to
nine at this point right we could almost
view that as the h axis but so that's h
is equal to 9. so at this point how high
are they
if this is h
so right now let me draw a little drop
go flat here so we want to set their
height above the ground so their height
above the ground is this distance
h which is the same thing as this
distance
h
so what is that distance
well it's going to be
well if this distance is h what is this
distance going to be
this distance is going to be 9 minus h
how do i know this this whole distance
is 9 this distance is h so let me do it
in a better color so that this distance
right here
is 9
minus h
so let's see what we can do what do we
know we know this distance we know this
angle is 18 degrees
and do we know this side sure that's the
radius that's eight eight meters
nine minus eight meters eight meters and
eighteen degrees
and and what are these sides relative to
this angle
well if we were to draw this if we draw
a right triangle here
and we relative to this angle right here
the nine minus h is adjacent and the
eight meters is of course the hypotenuse
right
so we could say so what what trig
function deals with adjacent and
hypotenuse
cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse so we
could say the cosine of 18 degrees
the cosine of 18t degrees
18t degrees is equal to its adjacent
side the adjacent side is 9 minus h
is equal to 9 minus h
over the hypotenuse
over eight
and now we can solve for h and we'll
have a have h as a function of t so if
you multiply both sides by eight you get
eight
cosine
of 18 t is equal to 9 minus h
maybe we can subtract 9 from both sides
so we get minus 9
plus 8 cosine of 18 t is equal to minus
h and then multiply both sides by
negative 1
and then you get
9 positive 9 right minus 8 cosine
of 18 t is equal to h or h
is equal to 9
minus
8
cosine
of 18 t so there we have it we have
expressed h as a function of t
and in the next video i'm actually going
to graph this function see you soon